e vi racconto brevemente la mia storia è
questa qua diciamo io ho finito
l'università a torino 45 anni diciamo
avuto tre fasi in una fase ho lavorato
in un'azienda ho fatto il manager
anzi più di un'azienda del 94 diciamo
più o meno mi occupo mi sono occupato di
internet prima in olivetti e poi in un
motore di ricerca americano
poi una seconda fase ho creato una mia
azienda quindi ho fatto la mia start up
circa nel 98 che è andata avanti negli
anni dalla quale poi appunto un altro
l'azienda che poi si è quotata in borsa
e poi uscito da questa esperienza
dopo aver fatto una pausa di riflessione
di un paio d'anni ho cominciato nel 2004
a incontrare tutta una nuova generazione
di imprenditori di giovani che dopo lo
scoppio della bolla della tecnologia
avvenuta nel 2000 stavano ricominciando
a fare start up amici ex diversi ex
colleghi semplicemente giovani che non
conoscevo e così è cominciato andare in
giro per prevalentemente l'italia a
cercare le nuove google e nuove facebook
cercare le nuove startup che stavano
nascendo un po dappertutto in italia
quindi sono passato dall'altra parte e
ho cominciato a fare l'investitore nel
2004 2005 quando abbiamo iniziato questo
lavoro devo dire la verità non c'era
ancora quel grande attività che c'è
adesso di dibattiti discussioni di
esposizione alla pubblica opinione anche
sui media delle startup c'erano poche
start up anche sommerse difficili anche
ad andare a trovare però poi negli anni
insieme ad alcuni amici che come me
hanno ricordano cominciato questa
esperienza di cercare occuparsi di start
up supportarle investire finanziarle
aiutare a crescere questo movimento è
cresciuto ad oggi è qualcosa un po
diciamo sulla bocca di tutti addirittura
entrato nell'agenda politica e stato un
viaggio affascinante e devo dire che
siamo solo all'inizio perché ho scoperto
un intera generazione completamente
nuova è completamente diversa
la mia che ha una dimensione è un modo
di interfacciarsi con queste tecnologie
di internet completamente diverso è la
generazione dei cosiddetti nativi
digitali e della generazione di quelli
che sono nati a differenza di me che
sono nato con un telecomando in mano e
così la mia generazione sono nati con un
computer in mano a me è capitato di
finanziare per esempio una società in
cui l'amministratore delegato ha 21 anni
eppure anche qua è un nostro ragazzo di
21 anni che quando mi scrisse il suo
progetto
allego il suo curriculum e sicuri
comodamente mente mi scrisse guarda io
21 anni scrivo software da quando dieci
anni
parlo di questa generazione generazione
che quindi è abituata a aprire le
macchine a tarocca hackerare i
telefonini e che rispetto alla mia
proprio perché a questa fortissima
esposizione ha una capacità di
immaginare il futuro decisamente
superiore abbiamo scoperto poi in questi
anni che questa generazione è
sparpagliata per l'italia non è solo
come si potrebbe essere al nord anzi
devo dire moltissimo e nelle stata più
interessanti che abbiamo trovato le
abbiamo trovate non è un fidanzato start
up non solo a milano è ormai andata
abbiamo finanziato start up in calabria
una start up di quattro ingegneri del
cnr che studiando in l'organizzazione
delle formiche hanno costruito un
algoritmo per risparmiare l'energia
elettrica nei data center parliamo di
risparmi molto significativi
abbiamo fatto ha fatto un calcolo è
stato legato di telecom che con la loro
tecnologia in grado di salvare di
rispondere circa un terawatt di energia
elettrica l'anno stiamo parlando
dell'energia che serve per illuminare la
città di milano
abbiamo investito punti cicero sulla
start up una società che è nata qui in
puglia un motore di ricerca basato sulla
stesso tecnologie semantiche un motore
di ricerca per il travel per i luoghi
che utilizza la semantica cioè la
capacità di computer di capire il
linguaggio e il significato delle parole
per fornire delle risposte alle domande
appunto nelle ricerche più più cose nei
più congruenti
abbiamo finanziato in sardegna una start
up che è forse una delle più innovativi
e rivoluzionari stat up che ho visto
decisamente negli ultimi anni in cui
sono le così nistrazione sar decs una
moneta complementare un circuito loro
chiamano di credito commerciale dove
mille imprenditori mille aziende sarde
si scambiano beni e servizi senza usare
gli euro ma usando questa moneta
virtuale chiamata sarde un sardo vale un
euro che si fonda interamente sulla
fiducia cioè il credito viene erogato
sulla base della fiducia della community
rispetto all'imprenditore e non genera
tassi di interesse non è un credito
speculativo
insomma in questi anni abbiamo ci siamo
resi conto che lavorando nelle
università italiane lavorando in giro
per i territori nei posti veramente più
come dire meno ovvi siamo andati con il
funzionamente a forza di scoprire che la
rinnovazione st sparpagliata in giro per
l'italia
abbiamo comprato un camper e devo dire
prima di renzi abbiamo comprato un
camper che mai chiamato barcamper e
l'abbiamo trasformato in una specie di
sala riunioni che ci consente di portare
alla salvioni dello straw ficio in giro
per l'italia tipicamente parcheggiamo il
camper dentro le università nei campus i
ragazzi si prenotano online un
appuntamento sul camper con noi e così
riusciamo a parlare con loro
face to face riusciamo a incontrare e
parlare discutere con con gli
imprenditori con i fondatori quei
ragazzi che hanno un progetto
direttamente con loro
questo però è molto importante anche
perché spesso i ragazzi in italia non
hanno le competenze per scrivere un
business plan l'università non li dota
di questi strumenti
a differenza delle business school
americane e per cui spesso i progetti
che ci arrivano in ufficio via email
sono difficilmente decodificabili mentre
invece riuscendo a parlare direttamente
faccia a faccia con con le persone
riusciamo a renderci conto veramente
della loro motivazione della loro idea
del mercato a cui stanno puntando
riusciamo ad apprendere contatto in
maniera molto più forte con i loro
progetti e riusciamo ad andare in
profondità dentro i territori in
calabria siamo andati da due anni noi
gestiamo la business plan competition
universitaria della calabria quest'anno
abbiamo ricevuto 100 progetti da tutte
le province della calabria
adesso minuti alcuni alcuni start upper
hanno preso l'aliscafo della sicilia per
finire sul camper a reggio calabria da
tutte le università da tutte le sedi
universitarie della calabria
insomma ci siamo resi conto in questi
anni di una cosa che c'è in italia un
potenziale enorme un potenziale
gigantesco assolutamente non sfruttato
secondo me per pigrizia prevalentemente
perché siamo siamo incrostati nella
pigrizia né nei ragionamenti i vecchi
nei vecchi schemi
abbiamo tre milioni e mezzo di ragazzi
disoccupati
questa è la generazione più formata e
meglio formata nella storia dell'italia
noi riceviamo curriculum presso
imbarazzanti dove io mi sento in
imbarazzo a fare il colloquio agente a
dai ragazzi che c'era un istruzione alla
formazione che un ordine di grandezza
superiore alla mia questo potenziale e
lì a nostra portata di mano può generare
grandissime nuove aziende e le aziende
che domani potranno competere con i
google con i facebook
dobbiamo solo stare ad ascoltarli grazie